bismillah hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
it's Christmas time is that time of the
year and we are excited to bring you
another show and Christmas it has some
connotations to Christ we believe in
Christ we love Christ Christ simply
means the Messiah in Hebrew Missy this
is Jesus Jesus the Messiah we love him
he's so dear to our heart and this
holiday revolves around him so we want
to help our brothers in humanity
understand the Muslim viewpoint and we
also want Muslims to understand
Christmas a little bit better so we're
gonna be here with our next guest dr.
Sabeel here on the D show don't go
anywhere
thank you for tuning in to the Dean show
we're here with dr. Sabeel
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam Haleiwa
God please be with you you too right
there thank you for finding the time to
be with us to talk about this very
important topic Christmas it involves
Jesus who we love respect one of the
mightiest messages of God no Muslim is a
Muslim unless you believe in Jesus some
people are like well then why aren't you
guys celebrating Christmas with us why
why are we covering this topic it's a
very important topic because it revolves
around Jesus Christ peace be upon him
who we love admire and respect so it's a
very important topic that not only we
should speak about Jesus Christ in the
Koran we should examine the teachings of
Jesus from the biblical point of view
and from historical point of view so we
could present a better picture to her
audience inshallah now many people are
in the holiday spirit you know they're
shopping they're celebrating and many
people aren't thinking like really
what's Christmas all about many people
believe as you know that Jesus was born
on this day many people believe that
he's God you know we love as I said you
know we are not trying to offend anybody
we just want people to understand things
a little bit better because some people
are just going with the flow and they're
not really investigating these things
they're looking into them so many
Muslims are also saying what's the
problem we love Jesus why don't we just
celebrate Christmas too so let's talk a
little bit about the origins and the
history from the Bible and also from
history itself and kind of just give
people an educated response to where
Christmas came from wonderful wonderful
let me ask you this question and the
audience are going to be asked this
question named this person who was born
more than 2,000 years ago who is
considered as God by some people and as
a mediator and he was born
the 25th of December now people are
gonna say that who is this person if I
if I mentioned these attributes of this
person consider is God born on the 25th
of December taken as a mediator who
would this person be born 2,000 years
ago people would say automatically now
that that is Jesus our brothers and
humanity will say that does Jesus and
what if I say that the answer is wrong
well then you can say produce your proof
all right wonderful now according to
encyclopædia Britannica in the ancient
times they used to be a person who was
called as matera the Persians the Romans
the Greeks the Egyptians they used to
believe in this person that he was God
he was the son of God that he was born
on the 25th of December so this was a
very prominent faith when Christianity
was developing around the Middle Eastern
region and they were migrating to Egypt
and to the Greek in the Roman Empire so
it so happened that as Christians the
disciples as they went to different
places they incorporated some of the
pagan beliefs of the Romans and the
Greeks and the Egyptians so that is how
the 25th of December was attached to as
the birth of Jesus that is how Jesus
Christ a human being as a prophet was
taken as a God any son of God and as a
mediator
so Christianity it incorporated the
beliefs of the pagan and the
polytheistic cultures as it was
expanding so are you telling us now that
in no way there's evidence that Jesus
peace be upon him was born on this day
correct so according to encyclopædia
Britannica there's a very valid very
authoritative source according to that
source it says that neither the mention
of the 25th of December is there in the
Bible nor the disciples they celebrated
on the twenty-fifth of December so
that's a fact that's a fact according to
the Encyclopedia Britannica and if you
go to the Bible itself
thousands of pages and thousands of
verses there's not a single mention in
there about the 25th of December as the
birth of Jesus in fact it says that when
Joseph when he moved from from Judea and
Bethlehem with his you know future wife
Mary Mother of Jesus peace be upon her
she gave birth and around that time the
Shepherd's they were going at night to
tend their flock of sheep this is
mentioned in the chapter of Luke chapter
2 verse number 4 to verse number 8 so
another question would be if shepherds
are going out on the 25th of December or
around their time what is the
temperature around their time according
to weather online.com the temperature in
the December in the last week of
December it goes to around freezing
degrees and Shepherds they don't go they
don't go out in that kind of a
temperature so according to Britannica
encyclopedia britannica and according to
the biblical sources Jesus Christ was
not born on the 25th of December now the
next question that arises comes to my
mind that is okay Jesus you said that
Christians believe that Jesus was God
celebrating Jesus's birth so our people
trying to say that God had a beginning
and that God was born because if Jesus
was God then God has certain attributes
right so God was born is this what
they're exposing - well I mean I hope
all of you agree up there that one of
the attributes of God is he is eternal
that means he's neither born never going
to die don't have parents doesn't have
any kids or children so if someone is
saying that God is born that means
they're just going against a fundamental
belief of the eternal nature of God in
fact if you go back to the Greeks and
the Romans they used to have guards who
were born right for example her Achilles
the son of zeus the god of the
he was born on the 25th of December
he also along with Mithra so you
mentioned wanna taking direct now
another pagan God whose name is again
her Achilles the son of Zeus okay so
which one is is a myth or her Achilles
then to complicate the picture Bacchus
the light God of the Romans he was born
in the 25th of December now people can
google this or they can go to an
Encyclopedia Britannica and and these
facts not fiction they can go
investigate this of course of course not
my opinion go back to the authoritative
secular sources you will find these
things so again we come back to the same
to the same notion that as Christianity
was spreading to different parts of the
world they incorporated many different
ideologies of the foreign cultures
including the 25th of December as the
birth of Jesus let's hold off right
there we're gonna take a break and be
right back with more discussing
Christmas the origins here with dr.
Sabeel on the Dean show we'll be right
back
well don't take the books put the books
in front of you and read them read the
Quran don't be afraid the question is
about whether Muslim power or not good
citizens the Constitution defines what a
good citizen is and the preamble it says
we the people of the United States know
how to form a more perfect union
establish justice insure domestic
tranquility to be Muslim they can say
that is a good Muslim and most Muslims
can say that most Muslims will embrace
as most persons are good Americans back
here on the Deen show talking about
Christmas Christmas is right around the
corner and we talked about you gave some
facts about Christmas and Jesus
definitely not being born on that day
and definitely that there are links
connecting it back to the pagan god
Mithra her oculus third one was backless
back is these are all gods at that time
that the Romans used to worship they
used to worship I mean obviously at one
time in history they may be just human
beings and later on people attributed
them to you know divinity guardship
but apparently they were all born on the
25th of December according to history
okay so yeah Santa Claus now you know
we're all told that this guy big heavy
guy fat guy is gonna come down to trim a
knee give you some gifts gifts and
exedra exedra what about this where
where's this come from again according
to the encyclopedia again there used to
be a saint
called Saint Nicholas in Denmark 300
years after Jesus Christ peace be upon
him supposedly he was a good Saint
giving gifts to the kids when he died on
the December 6th people started to you
know recognize his day of his death and
they started to give gifts again each
year on that day later on Queen Victoria
she changed that day of December 6th to
the night of 24th of December right so
from that point on everyone is now kind
of celebrating their day and you know
you have Santa Claus in the mall and
everyone is waiting for you know praying
that he could bring their gifts that he
could hear your prayers he knows if
you're a good kid or a bad kid so that
is how that custom came you know came
into Christianity very important thing
would be we are shifting again from God
to a person called Santa Claus
we are attributed we are we are giving
him the attributes of God saying that he
will know all the 7 billion people in
the world who is good and who is bad
that means we are telling that this
person is all-knowing instead of asking
from God we are asking from this person
called Saint Nicholas or Santa Claus so
it may have began as a you know benign
as a fun way of you know recognizing st.
Nicholas but again we are diluting the
monotheistic belief of Jesus Christ and
shifting it to a human being and giving
him those attributes of God so not
everything that's fun necessarily is
good you have to cross-reference and
check to make sure it's pleasing to the
crater that happens on earth now when
you start giving attributes of the one
create or the one created at Jesus
called us to worship you start saying
this man is all-knowing you know he's
the person that you're basically giving
one of the attributes that only belonged
to the crater the same Creator that
Jesus called people to worship that one
God now you're setting up a partner next
to him
right that's what's happening
unfortunately and it's based on a lie
too
it's based on you know that you know
it's based on a line and there's some
some people that will say no no I'm not
gonna you know lie to my kids because
tomorrow what I really want to tell them
about God they're gonna say well you
tell me this fairy tale and now you want
to tell me about the truth they're not
gonna accept it of course you know
according to the Quran according to the
Bible and according to just you know as
human beings we know that lying is wrong
yeah doesn't matter
for what reason that we're doing it it's
plain and like you know it's just wrong
to lie so if you're just saying that you
know Santa Claus is going to come and
bring in you know through the chimney
these gifts and you know there's hold on
and when they wake up on the 25th they
have all of these gifts and the parents
will say these were brought by Santa
Claus all of those things obviously you
know we as parents and we as human
beings we should refrain from yeah and
this holiday around you know Santa Claus
and all of that it goes into that that
aspect of lies yeah so we hope we're not
hurting anyone's feelings and for the
kids who believe this so long respect
your parents
be good to your parents and the one who
brings good is the crater that heavens
an earth so do good because God rewards
good isn't that better indeed indeed the
Christmas tree let's talk about this
where does this come from did to just
have any revelant any proof word in the
Bible was just something that Jesus he
told the people to do okay when it comes
to the Christmas trees and almost all
the Christians who are out there with
some exceptions and that 200 million in
the USA by the way in 2.1 billion in the
world they celebrate Christmas with the
Christmas tree
they bring it out from the forest or
they buy it from you know people who
bring it all from the forest they
decorated they put the gifts in there
and that becomes like a symbol of
Christmas in the USA close to 40 million
Christmas trees are sold each year for
at least 40 million 40 million each
Christmas tree it cost about $15 it's a
billion-dollar industry when we look at
the fact that they are close to forty
nine million fellow Americans of ours
who don't have enough to beat forty four
million people and our fellow Americans
who don't have insurance and about 15
million Americans they don't have jobs
are unemployed right so when you look
into this context and we celebrate with
the Christmas tree on the top of it
Jesus Christ peace be upon him and all
his disciples never had anything to do
with that tree in fact in the Old
Testament there is a verse the Book of
Jeremiah in the Old Testament chapter 10
I think you're gonna see this now go
ahead chapter 10 verse number three and
verse number four the God of the Bible
he says in the Old Testament that the
customs of the people they are worthless
this is in the Bible God is saying this
yes that the customs of the people
they're worthless they go to the forest
the chop down a tree they bring it home
and a craftsman it chooses Hill he
chooses the tree and then they decorate
the tree sounds like the Christmas tree
there's the Christmas tree
so God of the Bible is condemning the
practice of the Christmas tree whoo my
dear fellow Christians out there they
are celebrating Christmas with their
Christmas tree but if they go back to
the Old Testament and look at the
commandments of God this is one of the
commandments that God has forbidden now
someone's like look you guys you Muslims
you Moslems you always trying to mess up
our good time you know I was just about
to have some eggnog with some spicy
vodka and we're gonna celebrate families
coming together we got all these gifts
in that why are you guys messing up why
are you guys talking about this we're
just trying to have a good time how
would you respond to this well my
response to that wonderful intention of
our fellow Christians would be the focus
of our life is not a tree it's not a man
it is God so anything that we do and we
should do should revolve around God so
when we look at the teachings of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he always was
calling people to the worship of one God
and to obey the commandments of God so
if you look at from that angle yes we
may be having fun but we could still
have a nice benign fun without excessive
spending without involving in to any
innovations without without you know all
of the drinking and the dancing and all
the things immoral things sometimes that
may come about in these kind of
celebrations and the main thing is that
Jesus peace be upon him as a fact was
not born on this day he never called
people to worship him on his day nor did
he ever call people to worship Him or to
set up any kind of partner with him he
called people to worship the one unseen
crate or the same God that we worship
the same God that Jesus worship and this
is what basically Islam is called God is
calling us to do to live act to live
that and to revive that in our lives in
fact according to the Quran chapter 51
verse number 56 that the only purpose
that God has created humans and jinns is
that we should worship Him obviously
worshipping the one true God if you look
at Jesus peace be upon him his main
calling of the people is also to worship
on God if you look at the Gospel of Mark
chapter 12 verse number 28 and 29 some
people who they came to Jesus Christ
peace be upon him and they asked him
this very important question that of all
the commandments which one is the first
commandment and the Jews they used to
have 613 commandments so Jesus Christ
did not mention that the first
commandment is to believe in me as God
or son of God and believe in the Trinity
and there's two Christmas according to
Jesus peace be upon him the first
commandment he said that here o Israel
the Lord our God he is one Lord worship
Him with all your heart with all your
mind and with all your soul
and that is the first commandment so
look at this Jesus Christ was calling
people to worship one God in the Quran
chapter 3 verse number 51 Jesus Christ
also mentioned that worship your God and
my God who is Allah and that is the
straight path if you look at the
prophets of the Old Testament prophet
Abraham peace be upon him he did not
worship the Trinity he bowed down to the
one God
prophet Moses peace be upon him in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter 6 verse
number 4 he said hear o Israel the Lord
our God he is one God so the message of
all the prophets from the Bible and from
Jesus and from the Quran has been
consistent worship the creator and not
the creation very simple straightforward
we're gonna be right back to wrap it up
here on the Deen show you and my
daughter and me it's natural and he
created us to have a good time you
should have a good time without wise
though Islam is the fastest growing
religion in the world and most of the
converts are women not men they see that
the rules of Islam instead of
constraining them the rules set them
free
this is the back here on the Dean show
and we are talking about Christmas we
talked a little bit about the attributes
of the creator only worshiping him and
this was the true message of Jesus and
we talked about the pagan roots and
again not to offend anybody this is
case-sensitive and we love our brothers
in humanity and we want the best for
everybody so we're talking about this
because as you said it's not good enough
to just have a good intention it needs
to be backed up with knowledge to make
sure that it's pleasing to the one who
created us because ultimately that's
what we want to please the one create
tour so we talked about that let's talk
about the greeting as Muslims now you
know who obviously we love our neighbors
and we live amongst the people who we
want the best for and we should exchange
gifts and we should help our neighbors
in doing good
so some Muslims they feel like hey it's
their holiday I'm not celebrating it but
I wish the best to them Merry Christmas
to you too and a happy new year and all
the other fun stuff that goes fun stuff
that goes with it and you know what I
might even get you a glass of wine I
don't drink it the Quran says not to
drink wine but you know what I'm not
drinking it I'll get you a glass of wine
because you're my neighbor and I love
you what do you have you met some
Muslims like this well in fact you know
there's a very unfortunate that our
fellow Muslims sometimes they
also getting the spirit of this
Christmas which is not bad if you're
acknowledging Jesus Christ peace be upon
him as a prophet and trying to follow
his teachings which is submitting to one
God which is fine however when we are
giving Christians our Christian friends
a bottle of wine on Christmas and I have
seen some some people doing that
unfortunately just to please them and
just to acknowledge that we also are
with you they go out of the way and they
give something which is forbidden you
know to give the wine so in Islam to
drink to make and to give the all
forbidden about wine and alcohol and
intoxicants some Muslims unfortunately
because they see all of their Christian
friends and you know having all of this
fun they bring a small tree and they
tell their kids you know this is we are
also celebrating the birth of Jesus
there is also wrong because Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who is
appointed as the last and the final
prophet and he's been mentioned in
chapter 33 verse number 21 is the best
example to follow
he never celebrated his birthday Jesus
Christ never celebrated his birthday
neither any neither any of the prophets
so if we are going to follow all the
prophets we have to follow their
ideology we have to follow their actions
right so when we meet our Christian
friends yes we acknowledge that this is
your holiday but we love you just like
we love our own brothers and sisters all
of this love we would like to correct
you
I'll catch you about the message of
Jesus and about the message especially
of Islam because isn't it true now if
you as a Muslim or you now as a
Christian you say well Christians do
believe this some many don't all right
you know many people just slide in on
Sundays and they just go with the flow
that's what our fathers did but when you
explain it to them they're like you know
what this doesn't make sense
the whole Trinity God having a son God
being a man these things are confusing
so now the Muslims when they say okay
Merry Christmas
aren't you acknowledging now that God
had a son you're acknowledging this
Trinity and this is something that in
the Quran the verbatim word of God this
is something that is definitely a no-no
it's very much true when Muslims when
they greet back with the grading of in a
merry christmas' they are acknowledging
or they are legitimizing the the sonship
of Jesus or the divinity of Jesus or the
triune ideology of Christianity what
Muslims could say likewise would be when
they are greeted with Merry Christmas
they could say Happy Holidays and they
could again mention we love Jesus we
honor and respect him in fact our book
which is the Quran sent by God to
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him as a
guidance for all of humanity it mentions
Jesus many times with respect and his
message is mentioned here as a message
of oneness of God so we Muslims we
should convey to our fellow Christians
that Christianity is a faith about Jesus
and Islam is a faith of Jesus so if
anyone out there and all the Christians
I know they love Jesus should you not be
following the faith of Jesus and the
faith of Jesus or the ideology of Jesus
according to the oldest according to the
New Testament according to the Quran is
to submit and worship the one creator so
if you love Jesus follow his faith the
faith of Jesus was not Christianity
it was Islam so it's a good opportunity
for us now to engage and to educate to
talk to people about the one whose
beloved to our hearts Jesus peace be
upon him who no Muslim is a Muslim
unless we believe in Jesus but in no way
do acknowledge that he was born on this
day that he was God that he was a
literal son of God God doesn't have
children he doesn't have daughters he
doesn't have a DNA he doesn't have these
attributes that human beings have he
doesn't have a mother a father this is
not God this is what human beings do so
this is a good chance to talk to them
and to prove to them that look you know
we're on the same page we love Jesus but
no where did Jesus ever call people to
worship him so let's move a little bit
further and do what you were talking
about let's do what Jesus wanted us to
do and that's to worship the one guy not
to worship anyone besides God set up a
partner with God because this is
something that obviously God did not
sanction and
person is going to earn the displeasure
of God yes because we have to die one
day when we are standing in front of
garden on the day of judgment our
parents our church our environment our
friends they cannot come and save us on
the day of judgement when God is going
to ask us on the day of judgment what
did you believed in did you receive the
message of the oneness of God it will be
too late for any one of us to come back
to this life again and start submitting
to the one creator so it's very
important that we should not get
distracted by our family friends
environment just because they are doing
something we should not jump on the
bandwagon and start doing that God has
given each single one of a wonderful
mind we should use it examine the
history examine the scriptures and
specially try to read the Quran which is
the last verbatim Word of God and if you
do that one simple message comes very
clear that God created Adam and Eve give
them one core message submit to God the
same message was given to all the
prophets including Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and that message
submission to one God in Arabic language
it means Islam so if you want to follow
an ideology of Jesus and Moses and
Abraham and all the prophets of God and
peace and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him follow their ideology that ideology
was submit only to one God which equals
Islam simple straightforward and how if
people want to get a hold of you and you
know if they have some questions about
this say you know I think you got it
wrong and they want to talk a few and
dialogue with you and you know hook up
with you how can they get a hold of you
okay wonderful on behalf of gain peace
which is a project of the Islamic circle
of North America
we have a live toll-free telephone line
800 662 Islam 866 to Islam anyone could
pick up a phone give us a call and have
a nice friendly conversation with us and
if you would like to know more about
Islam and would like to get a free copy
of the Quran in English language
we could send you a free copy no strings
attached so learn Islam from the source
and then make up your mind and we hope
and pray that once you read the Quran
you will understand the truth and the
truth is worship the creator and not the
creation thank you very much my God
Almighty the credit reward you we hope
to have you back again next time here on
the Deen show take care nice to be here
assalamu alaikum peace be upon all of
you alaykum sang and that was it for
another episode of the deanship islam
says to islam islam says love all
mankind and inside of the love because
we love our brothers in humanity that we
want to deliver and educate people with
the truth and you have gotten to see the
origins of Christmas and you've got to
learn that Muslims love love Jesus peace
be upon him and it's always been one
sender one recipient the one creator
sent the message to one mankind and it
wasn't religions it's always been one
religion one way of life and that way of
life has been to have a direct
connection a relationship with the one
who created you to submit yourself
entirely wholeheartedly to the one God
the same God that Jesus called all of us
to submit to nowhere did ever as we
talked about the Jesus never copied with
to worship Him he never never expressed
that but he always expressed that you
loved the create toward that you worship
the creator and you never set up a
partner with the Creator and that's the
message of Islam Islam has been there
since time immemorial so why don't you
get to know Islam
get to know your Muslims call us